bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors les sodia
n'apprécie pas vraiment les propos tenus
par le ministre libanais et ses
partenaires non plus
bonjour oui le visiblement basse-terre
queue leu leu l'arabie séoudite
considère
le liban comme un pays vassal d'ailleurs
comme l'a redit si dit considère le
koweït et bahreïn comme des pays vassaux
donc tout discours qui pourrait être
allé à l'encontre du discours officiel
et est aussitôt condamné ce qu'il faut
quand même remarquer c'est que georges
kordahi la halle qui avait fait cette
annonce alors qu'il n'était pas encore
nommé ministre
en fait ils dénoncent un camp et prend
parti pour l'autre donc il y a également
à l'intérieur de cette déclaration une
lutte contre entre les pro assad puisque
lui et pro et sa béquille aucun moment
on l'a entendu dénoncé les interventions
étrangères
en syrie de la part notamment de la
russie et il souffre et il y fait un
soutien clair auprès des outils qui sont
aussi responsables de crimes de guerre
dans la situation de la guerre au yémen
donc on n'est pas sur une situation de
dénonciation des crimes contre
l'humanité qui sont
actuellement dans son mythique dont est
victime actuellement la population du
yémen mais on est plus sur un rapport de
force entre
toujours que cette scéne triangulaire
entre l'iran l'arabie saoudite et lui
bon alors il ya ce conflit à marib en ce
moment c'est certainement le plus
meurtrier on a des raids meurtriers car
quasiment tous les jours un dernier en
date est me semble que c'était
avant-hier plus de 80 morts parmi les
outils selon la coalition militaire est
ce que il ya bien une intensification
des combats dans cette zone ces
dernières semaines
c'est difficile de savoir parce que
d'abord nous on n'a pas les moyens de se
voir personne sur place et comme eux les
informations sont filtrés à la fois de
la part de la coalition des pays dirigés
par l'arabie saoudite et les émirats
arabes unis faut pas oublier émirats
arabes unis même s'ils disent qu'ils se
sont retirés il continue de tirer les
ficelles derrière et puis les outils les
outils ont la même paranoïa et de ce
point de vue là
déjà dans les conflits en général c'est
difficile de connaître véritablement
quels sont les pertes humaines mais là
ça l'est encore plus
d'ailleurs où sont les ong les grandes
ong internationales qui à l'époque où
j'ai pas retenir l'une d'entre elles
envoyer des personnes sur place pour
faire des enquêtes et essayer de dire au
monde
l'insupportable
c'est malheureusement aujourd'hui pour
le cas du yémen une situation qui tu
extrêmement et qui est extrêmement
terrifiante pour les populations mais
dont on sait finalement peu de choses au
quotidien la gare au yémen en quelques
mots c'est un début il ya plusieurs
années maintenant c'est en 2014 des
dizaines de milliers de deux personnes
la plupart des civils ont été tuées vous
le rappeliez 1 on n'a pas de chiffres
exacts des milliers de déplacés une
famine avec des milliers d'enfants qui
risquent de mourir de faim et une pire
crise humanitaire au monde selon l'onu
avec tout ce que je viens de dire
pourquoi on n'en parle pas assez de
cette guerre
non monsieur sur les chiffres que vous
avez annoncé les nations unies vont plus
loin puisqu'il parle de plus de 1000 fin
2009 il a fait une estimation qui était
plus de 230 mille deux cent vingt mille
morts
dans la guerre du yémen depuis donc
décembre 2009 on peut imaginer qu'en une
année avec intensité des combats etc les
chiffres et la situation
humanitaire c'est à dire que la
coalition bombarde systématiquement les
hôpitaux ce qui reste des hôpitaux
d'ailleurs les champs les pêcheurs quand
ils veulent et les péchés enfin essayé
d'étrangler au prix complètement
d'otages
population civile du yémen donc ça c'est
une situation que l'on connaît qu'on
évalue encore une fois mais pourquoi on
ne sait rien il ya une des raisons pour
laquelle on ne sait rien c'est que par
exemple en france le gouvernement
français complices de ces crimes contre
l'humanité et crimes de guerre
vend des armes auprès de la coalition et
que pour le gouvernement français
aujourd'hui et le président de la
république emmanuel macron c'est plus
important de vendre des armes que de se
soucier du droit international il le
deuxième facteur c'est également un
facteur de comment de communication
l'arabie saoudite
a mandaté une agence de communication
que car acheter ou publicis de madame
badinter a qui défend le voile des
femmes
afghanes mais qui visiblement se fiche
complètement de la mort de centaines de
milliers d enfants et d'abord des femmes
yéménites donc là de ce point de vue là
il ya un travail extrêmement efficace de
la part de publicis dans d'autres pays
les meilleurs bleus saxon il ya
également deux autres
agences de communication qui ont été
cornaqué par
l'arabie saoudite
et puis il ya toujours cette relation de
chantage et de menaces qu'exerce
l'arabie saoudite on a vu quand le
canada avait commencé à critiquer un
petit peu les cris mais la cause et de
la situation des femmes en arabie
séoudite il avait été rappelé à l'ordre
au risque d'ailleurs d'annuler un
contrat de véhicules blindés en
direction de l'arabie saoudite et puis
des pays qui eux auraient la
potentialité de d'affirmer et de
d'affluer sur les décisions du
gouvernement fait pas du gouvernement de
mohamed bin salman comme la russie la
chine se taisent dramatiquement
benoît mur ascione merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes président de l'association as their
marseillais fou